levi ist nicht das was soll hier sonst
rauskommen ein apfel oder was etwas
glaubt und jetzt willkommen beim neuen
video ja ich bin gerade in köln ich weiß
schon die qualität ist krass oder seiner
jährlich die qualität ist krass oder
hilft ich auf jeden fall sind wir heute
zu zweit in köln ich habe noch wie ein
ganz liebes hinter der kamera setzen
hallo wir sind jedem angekommen und
haben uns gedacht hey was sollen wir
drehen so also wir haben so ein paar
ideen aber irgendwas geil ist und
genauer halt von dieser location genau
hier gegenüber ist einfach ein sexshop
ja genau ich weiß nicht ob ihr das video
gesehen habe da habe ich so frauen
produkte getestet die hat mir meine
freunde oder so glaube ich gegeben und
dann habe ich halt getestet so geguckt
was es ist und genau das gleiche machen
wir heute auch und zwar teste ich auf
meinem channel drei oder vier ich weiß
wie viel hast du gekauft drei perverse
frauen produkte aus diesem shop und ich
muss halt erraten was es ist dass es
halt alles so ein bisschen komisch so
das kann man vielleicht durch ein
äußerst gutes aufsuchte er hat habe ich
was gutes rausgesucht ich bin heftig
gespannt das ding war wie kann in diesem
shop seien alle blicke so auf uns so was
wollen sie hier so komplett falsches
publikum glaube ich nicht okay heute ist
doch egal auf jeden fall da waren zwei
verdiener bediener nie wie nennt man die
doch mal so so kunden bediener in diesem
shop und der mann alter das war so ein
richtig komischer typ ohne scheiß
sondern richtig zu dem passt zu 100
prozent einen sexshop fand es nicht doch
auf jeden fall fangen jetzt an mit dem
video ich bin ready was machst du da
gerade ist das also okay wir vergangenes
produktnummer äußerst wohl hier ist es
ja wieviel hast du davon geholt
ja ist gut dass zimmerleute produkt
nummer eins ich weiß ja wie das gut
sehen können wie man das sieht richtig
täglich aus was tut man leute also dass
vorne hier dran ist das männliche
geschlechtsorgan das sehe ich auch
sofort nein ich mache ich mach das nicht
yoga ist wenn ich wie man sieht welches
mädchen bin ich vielleicht was aber nein
ich mache das nicht dass und pds
strohhalme für welche sag mir bitte für
welchen anlass für welchen anlass sollte
gibt's so was fällt dir eine sonde 1
keine chance wieso stellt man sowas
herstelle vor so du bist gefragt was
machst du beruflich - olg hielt alles
klar wie viel hast du davon geholt
sie können gerne passe mit euch
veranstalten und da gibt's dann free
press strohhalme wenn ihr bock drauf
habt lasst mal daumen nach oben
okay vielleicht mit dem nächsten produkt
das ist sowas
ganz ehrlich das sieht auch irgendwie
das könnte auch so ein bonbon also so
was lecker sein soli oder sowie zum
lutschen
das ist halt so ein ding hier steht
drauf youtube und das kann man an waffen
durch das mal machen
da muss die batterie rein jetzt wie von
folien als wenn man drin folie exakt
muss jetzt noch angeht nicht werden
okay leute jetzt funktioniert also ich
mach das jetzt an aber das immer noch
klein
ja wo das
ja sie zwischendurch wäre besser das
voll geil ich hole mir auch so was aber
so als massage machen wir mal weiter
gemacht das letzte produkt was ist das
ich hab voll hunger toll dass die banane
die man überhaupt etwas machen wir
gerade wieder finden wie hier ohne
scheiß ich weiß schon was hier
rauskommen nein sich nach osten link dvi
ist nicht das was was soll hier sonst
rauskommen tafel oder was warum gibt es
so was ehrlich warum ist das anders das
ist doch voll eklig man es kaufen sowas
kauft man sich doch nicht als frau
bereits von der kassen davon so was
überhaupt auf youtube stellen so was
jetzt stunde muss das zensieren lena 10
euro 10 euro an
für zehn euro kann man sich so tolle
sachen kaufen aber doch nicht so etwas
ekliges das stinkt sie täglich aus und
wahrscheinlich verstehen die meist nicht
mal den sinn und nehmen einfach die
banane
ihr wisst ich denke ich dir kannst du
behalten leute das war's mit dem
dümmsten video was ich jemals auf
youtube hochgeladen habe beziehungsweise
werde hoffe ich hinter der kamera macht
so zweiter teil ab so genau
ich hab natürlich fiel jedoch drei
produkte gehörten jedoch 34 keine ahnung
ich hab mich noch brutto gekauft ich
habe für ihn auf jeden fall durch
produkte gekauft das sind allerdings
meiner produkte deswegen ich wette damit
kennt er sich aus der realität so fort
was das ist deswegen ist natürlich auch
in der video beschreibung verlinkt check
dass man noch abwenden wollen sonst
würde es mich freuen euch das video
gefallen hat und was jetzt noch um da
wir sehen uns schon am freitag wieder um
14 uhr kommt ein neues video von mir ja
heute schon instagram eingeblendet ich
sagt schauen aber noch weiter folgt mir
da folgt auf insgesamt fünf
manchmal denkt